la moitié des 130 centres de tri postaux
en france sont également grève contre la
réforme de la sécurité sociale et
solidaire avec les cheminots reportage à
rouen d'abord et dans d'autres centres
pascal golomer l'uck baptisé ici on
n'est pas en grève pour des intérêts
étroits égoïsme de catégorielles on est
en grève contre le plan juppé
la ligne le centre de tri de sotteville
lès rouen bloqués depuis lundi soir
depuis le vote de la grève la main levée
trois assemblées générales chaque jour
est toujours le même mot d'ordre qui
revient dans les conversations
non à la casse des acquis sociaux non à
la remise en cause les régimes de
retraite beaucoup de collègues disait
est ce qu'on va subir toutes les
attaques
à chaque fois en répondant juste 24
heures souhaité aller plus loin le fait
que les cheminots et montrer la voie
c'est le cas de le dire a décidé
d'actions ce soir 50 des 130 centres de
tri de la poste sont occupés avec 50 à
90% de grévistes
une grève qui ne s'étant pour l'instant
qu'à une vingtaine de bureaux à paris
grenoble lyon valence soyez-en les
guichets reste ouvert les facteurs font
encore leur tournée et la distribution
du courrier pourrait devenir de plus en
plus chaotique que les jours qui
viennent si le mouvement se poursuit et
c'est bien l'intention des principaux
syndicats qui appellent partout à la
grève reconductible